brought to you by the PlayStation
experience in Las Vegas take part in all
the announcements panels and early game
previews December 6th and 7th hey guys
my name is Jess McDonald today is the
25th of November and you're tuned in to
guess what news let's learn some stuff
Nintendo is having a really good year
after the slow start for their wii u
thanks to the successes of Mario Kart 8
and now super smash brothers the game
we're adorable wide-eyed characters beat
the crap out of each other has overtaken
Mario Kart 8 as the fastest selling wii
u game in the u.s. four hundred and
ninety thousand copies have been shifted
in the space of three days and that's
including physical and digital units
Nintendo of America marketing exec Scott
Moffitt said that while Nintendo's
holiday season is off to a great start
they still have work left to do he also
dropped a hint that Nintendo has a few
more surprises in store for fans it's
expected that Smash Brothers will
continue to sell well when the game is
released across Europe Australia and
Japan particularly considering its
predecessor super smash brothers brawl
sold more than 12 million units
worldwide strange Kickstarter's have
been cropping up all over the place and
one that saps your blood as you play
games certainly qualifies as strange so
strange in fact that Kickstarter have
suspended it the concept was that every
time your in-game character suffered
damage blood would be drawn from your
body as the controller rumbles the
process would then stop when you've
reached the set blood donation quantity
it's sort of a cool idea to fuse gaming
events and blood drives but it seems
Kickstarter had some sort of problem
with it since they've opted to suspend
the project with no explanation I mean
oh you think the idea is cool or silly
and dark souls 2 is making its way over
to ps4 xbox one and DirectX 11 capable
pcs as of april of next year the new
version is called scholar of the first
sin and collects dark souls 2 and all of
its
you'll see in one handy package from
software are also promising enhanced
graphics in addition to brand new game
content including an expanded story
featuring additional in-game events and
NPC characters along with new deadly
enemies and gameplay improvements if you
like the sound of that but don't have a
fancy new platforms the devil also
making the package available on last gen
you'll get all the content but not the
enhanced graphics and sound as for your
question of the day let me know if
you're keen to play this extended
edition of Dark Souls 2 if you're after
one year's you can head to gain swap the
stories on 343 continuing to apologize
for halos multiplayer issues and JRPGs
coming to the Xbox one that is it for me
today thanks for joining me and be sure
to come back same time tomorrow for our
last episode of GS knees before the
Thanksgiving break I will see them